so we have this story from axios state's
leapfrog federal government in
restraining tech
so axios reports states across the u.s
unwilling to wait for the slower gears
of the federal government to turn are
moving aggressively to regulate the tech
industry why it matters
states famously serve as laboratories of
democracy testing out innovative laws
that other states or the federal
government can adopt but their
experiments can sometimes be half-baked
or have unintended consequences and the
regulations can run afoul of the courts
the big picture the one thing i i want
to highlight in this is
the fight against censorship they they
say closer to the bottom
our thought bubble growing partisan
polarization at the state level
guarantees the introduction and
potential passage
of more party-line tech bills that
wouldn't stand a chance of moving
forward
in the more narrowly divided federal
government it's likely for instance that
we'll see more proposals out of red
states aimed at punishing tech
for perceived censorship of
conservatives while blue states may
follow maryland's lead on digital taxes
among other tech priorities okay this is
a good thing about america
but you gotta understand where this
might lead to i say it's a good thing
because
if the federal government won't stop the
big tech companies that are shutting
down
free speech and censoring people the
states can do it on an individual level
ron desantis of florida recently
announced they're gonna be proposing
this bill
that would punish big tech companies for
censoring political individuals and
regular people giving the right to
appeal and things like that we also
heard other countries may do something
similar don't you don't get me wrong
it's not just about america
but in this country the way the states
are divided up
you could go move to florida if you want
protections against big tech censoring
you
if they pass this law but where this
goes
what happens if florida says free speech
must be guaranteed
and they tell twitter facebook youtube
if you ban people we will find you a
million dollars
well the big tech companies might say
fine we won't operate in your state at
all and then the state and the people
who are there will have to come up with
their own solutions for social
networking and
financial services good and it will
happen because they're not just going to
be like oh no no immediately you're
going to see your investors being like
this is our opportunity to move into
this state
and seize up 30 million new customers so
then what's the alternative
the big tech companies will say okay in
your state only anybody who's there
whose ipaddress registers from your
state
will have free and open access and no
censorship but then in new york state
they say you must ban all the hate
speech new york becomes deep blue where
it's dominated by only woke far left
cultists
and florida becomes a free speech
free-for-all the people in florida
are more likely to have access to open
information to be challenged to be
de-radicalized
and the people in new york will
hyper-radicalize into an insane ideology
controlled by those big tech companies
and then propped up by the uniparty that
controls the state
like i was saying earlier it ultimately
leads to people dividing
up red people in red areas blue people
in blue areas and then entrenching in
their beliefs
and then eventually throwing things at
each other i totally agree with that but
i think
i think it should i think florida should
do that i think
we all should do that and listen if new
york
wants to make it so tech can sense
everybody they're gonna really hurt
themselves creativity
all the creative people are gonna move
to florida and then they're gonna
pay a deep price for that brain drain
that's what they call it uh when a lot
of people flee countries because they're
not allowed to express themselves freely
in other countries
and and i'm even thinking about moving
to florida myself to be honest
thinking about my baby's mama would be
open to it you can buy guns
yeah you walk in you got your id you
could buy a gun it's one of the easier
states
you got freedom uh it's hot and muggy
all the time
i know and they got alligators dude
and then and then you become florida man
yep which is a secret
i lived in miami for a couple years
actually really close to that
that you know migrant detention center
that was all over the news and uh
it rains all the time the rain's kind of
awesome it's like you're in a monsoon
whenever it rains lizards everywhere
it's so cool we would go out and just
catch geckos and lizards
and then bring them in to deal with the
bugs because there's a lot of bugs
there's bugs everywhere
so i'm like here's your choice giant
bugs all over the house
or lizards all over them yeah that's
what it is
tampa's got chickens just running around
yes yeah we're kidding
place no yes so like where i lived we'd
just like be driving down the street
there'd be chickens everywhere yeah and
they were someone's chickens
and the chickens would just go home
later and we but here's the other thing
too we also had like
we had uh problems with illegal
immigrants who were coming in
there were home invasions they're you're
out in the middle of nowhere
not a lot of cops that's the trade-off
man if you want to be responsible of
yourself
be responsible for yourself live out the
middle of nowhere you might see more
crime
you might see chickens running around
there might be a rafter of turkeys
running through your yard or something
you gotta chase them off or
control the turkey and deer populations
maybe that's responsibility but you have
the choice you have the freedom
you can do what you want on your
property did you get nailed by a
hurricane while you were there
no we almost did i think i think we
almost did it that makes you nervous
though
no hurricanes in there and the house the
house we had had uh
uh shutters like these hurricane
shutters you got
you were inland even a little bit there
were miami what are you talking about
i remember visiting you i remember we
bought some chickens yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we like
the loose
inland is relative bro we were in miami
we were we were within a couple dozen
miles of the coastline in the flood
plains
so like we were like ah go to the second
floor when the hurricane comes i guess
because we don't want to flood
i had questions about this social media
acting in florida and in new york so if
you were a florida resident and you
could post and they're like okay we're
not going to censor anyone in florida
you'd see everybody that posted in new
york yeah but if you were in new york
would then you just not see the stuff
that's exactly that all right
that's all right but then if you
responded to that one of their comments
they just wouldn't see your response
you'd wonder why aren't they responding
to me so would they have to block
everyone no no no what happens right now
is that if you're if you can do this
with a vpn so those are listening
if you have a vpn say virtual shield you
can
turn your vpn to say germany and then go
on twitter
and you'll see a bunch of tweets where
it says this violated german law
so you'll see the response violation of
german law things like that
so people were doing experiments with us
a while ago they may have changed it so
it doesn't say that anymore
but it uses something you'd get a
message saying this tweet is in
violation of you know this country so
you can't see it
so you know it's there you can't look at
it so actually when you drive
through states depending on what that
state's
politics are i've had people tell me
that the news
that they kind of get force-fed on your
phone changes
depending on what political leanings
that state is definitely definitely
because it's all about how ads are
served
so if you're in a red area they're going
to assume you want to see
red news outlets so if they want to make
money
they got to do it the daily wire they
run ads on facebook
the only reason they would do that is if
the ads generated eyeballs for their
site which allows them to make money
if the cost of the ad is is if if
they're spending more money on ads than
they're making
they stop doing it so facebook says we
need to make sure these ads have a big
impact
and work for the daily wire so if you're
in a red area
more likely to get it and i'm sure the
daily wire chooses some of these metrics
too saying we want people in
conservative areas
who are this age and you know and are
likely to be male or whatever i don't
know if they care about gender but you
can do that too
they can even do religions and things
like that so yeah you go you drive in
your notifications are going to change
yeah and it's just it's hyper polarizing
everything
it's just the dominoes falling over man
it's gonna it's gonna get real weird and
freaky when you're like
you're gonna be in west virginia or
wyoming or something and then you're
gonna look at your phone and it's gonna
be
like wow the world's on fire and then
you you turn on new york vpn
and it's all you know candy canes and
rainbows and people holding hands and
singing
and then you're like i can literally see
the country burning to the ground around
you
but you're isolated in this bubble and
you have no idea what's going on that's
what's
kind of it's kind of what's going on
right exactly right
people are getting what the information
they want maybe not the information they
need
and i just see it happening it's just an
interesting thing you have these blue
check marks and i always say block is if
you don't know who they are and somehow
you'd be like
i'm the editor of wacky monkey magazine
right
and i got 400 000 subscribers like how
did you get
that many followers it's unbelievable
man
there are channels on youtube that do
nothing but like get a molten hot a red
hot nickel ball
and then like melt things with it there
are channels that just crush things in
hydraulic presses
i had an idea for starting the
electrocution channel where we
electrocute random objects
my idea though was the the the voltage
would be based on the amount of live
viewership
or shares so then you got to tell
everybody keep sharing keep sharing
we're getting enough views and then you
know increase the voltage or whatever
or amperage or wattage whatever i'm not
an electrician and uh but the point is
people really can isolate one particular
thing that entertains them and they
watch it forever
you hear what you like we goes back it
goes back to reagan
taking away the opposite opinion now we
got two
networks two cable news networks telling
you
what you want to hear yeah you were
saying reagan um
that before reagan you every time a news
network would air an opinion that they
would have to show legally
the opposite opinion is that what yeah
it was like a famous thing was the
garrison files where this
law this uh lawyer garrison went on
television
said he had the right to tell that side
of the kennedy
assassination and that's kind of why
they took it away man
you know here's my whole thing about the
social media and hollywood and all that
stuff
is like it's all ran by rich kids man
rich kids
real you know like i said malcolm x and
and
uh you know the unabomber both said rich
liberal kids are the thing and
you know why do why do rich people want
more taxes well because they have
accountants
that can figure out how to not pay those
taxes well it's right it's it's actually
simple
if you make 100 million dollars and you
pay a
very high progressive percentage it
doesn't matter to a rich person
because the percentage isn't what
matters so i'm actually in favor of
progressive tax and i'll explain
so and and even they are too it's a
complicated process that the issue is
we need bigger and bigger tax brackets
up you know higher and higher you go
if someone has 100 million dollars per
year in liquid cash coming in which is
like obscene it doesn't happen
and they pay 60 in taxes they still have
40 million dollars
to invest and look power attracts power
that kind of money
you can make a ton of investments risk
nothing
you can go on on robinhood and put it
all in gamestop because you don't care
about dumping a million what does it
matter to you you make a hundred
you know it's it's a drop in the head
you can take big risks and make big
money and you have little to worry about
because you only need a couple hundred
to live comfortably like a wealthy
person you got a bunch of houses you own
you don't care you can do whatever you
want and then the cash is there
but if if someone who makes two hundred
thousand is paying the same percentage
then they only have what seventy
thousand to actually spend
they have no money to invest so what
ends up happening is
uh this way i'm not a fan of the flat
tax if
if we had a really high flat tax or the
problem we have now is the price of tax
stops after like i think
350 or something people who make just
above that
are struggling to actually grow and move
upward to become the ultra wealthy
elites and actually run
these businesses and the ultra-wealthy
elites are creating shields for
themselves the more taxes they create
it keeps people from becoming from
becoming wealthy
the more taxes they put on the harder it
is to move up
for sure for regular people most tax i
mean the
the federal income tax was signed by
woodrow wilson like a thief in the night
on christmas eve
i mean it's just a fact there was never
a vote on it and we never had it before
that we were supposed to only play
taxes well for when to win the war for
war
the real the real issue is the federal
res federal reserve gives them the
ability to control the flow of the
economy and
and how the com how the country's and
the taxes is just a way of recuperating
and
facilitating the machine you know what i
mean you know you know what my favorite
taxes
what no tax yeah but it's not just taxes
it's also
regulations it's also rules it's also
inspections it's also all the little
middle management things that the
government takes as a way of supposedly
helping people
but they're created by the big people
who keep people down
it's the corruption yeah it's the
corruption if a bunch of people got
together
and said anybody who works on let's see
let's save 100 acres of land
and you got a bunch of your friends 100
of your friends each live on one acre
and they're all living on this property
and there's a stream and this one dude
keeps taking a dump in it
and you all get together and say from
now on no one's allowed to take a dump
in the stream you've just regulated the
stream usage
that's a good thing that's well that's
because
they did this on purpose they made it
regulation so everyone flip out
i have no problems with protections
right i mean if they called it
protections
i think we'd be okay with that well
listen that's what it is
the issue is when one guy goes to
you know a plurality not even a majority
and says hey if we all collude together
we can trick everybody into diverting
the stream onto our properties so we
have more access
and we'll call it a regulation oh no
although we have to do it i'm so sorry
that's the problem they've the system
has become corrupted and tainted yeah
rules are fine when the rules benefit
the people i'm not a laissez faire
capitalist
i think we need some regulations the
problem is our social programs and our
regulations
are typically to benefit the wealthy to
cheat to change the rules 100 help them
out the taxes do that
the stimulus does that and the
regulations do that it's a revolving
door of corruption
meant to keep the poor poor and not
allow for legitimate capitalism
i say get rid of fee of entry that's the
number one way that you control
people's ability to move i mean look at
what we're doing with doctors
when you come out of med school you're
so deep in debt you don't have a lot of
room to maneuver
to even set up your own practice so you
got to go into these plug-and-play
situations where if you don't play ball
with these
these pharmaceutical companies the
health care system
you good luck on growing okay and then
if you want to open the restaurant like
why do i like food trucks
because i think that's a way to just go
boom you're getting right into it
and you're starting to make money and to
open a restaurant you have to have
so much money to open a restaurant that
is fee
of entry that allows the elites to be
able to
move and create stuff where the players
that's a lot harder that's the point i
was saying about
a flat tax or a limited progressive tax
because
you could tax a guy who makes a hundred
million dollars at 80 percent he still
has 20 million dollars he can snap his
fingers and make 10 food trucks
whereas a regular guy who's being taxed
at 10 but only makes a hundred thousand
a year can't do that
so i get it i understand it's not like
this person deserves it or doesn't
deserve it the amount of money doesn't
determine whether you're a hard worker
or not
i'm just saying i think a progressive
tax makes more sense
but admittedly this isn't particularly
complicated thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time